Oh what's going on you two check it out
so uh occasionally there'll be a video
that I'll make vanilla they'll even
surprise me there's a whole bunch of
ideas running in my head so there'll be
times where I'll just said to myself and
just think about skids in my head and
I'll start laughing to myself in public
people find that a little crazy for
those of you who don't know about a
couple months ago I made a character
called crumb t Dumpty
he's a dance character aka Wiggles
McNichols slash tickle B elbow you know
I'm saying and so this this this next
clip is a company Dumpty episode but um
at a certain point it just it just
starts to go incredibly weird this video
is just it's something else you just
gotta watch for yourself check it out as
a b-boy where do I stand you know
dancing is not about you know showing
off and who's better or what not
probably dance tiles if I mastered
here's a better question how many dance
tiles haven't I mastered what are my
people specialties the head spin
[Music]
dance is all about being flexible you
need to be able to move
[Music]
you arachnophobia maybe you haven't seen
my spider
[Music]
b-boying is all about conditioning about
strength training have you seen this
before
[Music]
that's right I'm plus-sized but you
didn't know how to do a backward did you
[Music]
didn't think I was flexible did you
rubber legs oh damn I could say anything
is the b-boys name cross eyes yeah
there's people across idea what why was
water created to hydrate me why did God
give you legs to walk over and see me
why did God give you a nose to pick it
for me
[Music]